what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and yesterday we got our very first look
at Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in Deadpool
3. his triumphant return and in his
classic Wolverine yellow suit everyone
of course is rightfully freaking out
about it and can't wait to see even more
but yesterday we did also get some set
footage of a fight between Deadpool and
Wolverine now the fight itself is really
really awesome and shows us a few really
cool things but there are also some
things in the background of this video
that tell us a little bit about what
Deadpool 3 is going to be about they
back up some of the rumors that we've
heard recently and back up a few of the
leaks that have been out there recently
as well and they show us that Deadpool
is going to be breaking the fourth wall
just as he did before in the other two
Deadpool films if not possibly even more
in this film and because of a huge
fourth wall break in this video it looks
like we might know a major plot point of
Deadpool 3 which of course will break
down in this video but first let's start
with this epic fight scene that we're
going to see in Deadpool 3 and if you
want to stay up to date on the latest
MCU news be sure to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
we're also doing a huge giveaway we'll
talk about that at the end so like I
mentioned set footage did get released
yesterday from the set of Deadpool 3
where we see Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds
and their stunt doubles performing some
pretty cool stunts for a fight scene
that is going to take place between
Deadpool and Wolverine this is what was
promised to us if you recall the First
videos where Ryan Reynolds announced
that Hugh Jackman was returning the
first one was pretty nonchalant Hugh
Jackman was walking in the background
Ryan Reynolds said hey do you want to
come back and Hugh Jackman said yeah
sure but the second one gave us a little
bit more information Hugh Jackman came
on screen with Ryan Reynolds and talked
about what to expect and two important
things one is that they told us that
they weren't going to undo anything that
happened in Logan alive yeah after Logan
Logan takes place in 2029 totally
separate thing Logan died in Logan not
touching that
what actually happens in our film
and they technically aren't but at the
same time they kind of are because it
looks like they're going to take
Wolverine from that timeline and create
a new different timeline so the timeline
will continue to go on where Logan will
eventually die but a branch timeline
will go off into Deadpool 3 which is
where we'll see our Wolverine so
technically no they are not undoing that
our Wolverine will technically be a
variant he'll just pretty much be the
same Wolverine however he will have
experienced the same past things all the
past events that Logan would have
experienced so keep that in mind going
into Deadpool 3 but also they showed us
that they are going to fight with each
other they teased us with this they
talked about the fight but as soon as
they start fighting with each other
playfully their mics cut out and music
cut in we can't play the actual music
Jitterbug because of copyright reasons
but you get it
but what is interesting about this is
they show each other basically stabbing
each other Ryan Reynolds of course with
the sword Wolverine with his claws and
that's exactly what we see in this scene
here it's almost like they were talking
about this exact scene right here we see
them both on scene in the first action
that we see is Wolverine has sort of
thrown Deadpool on the ground it looks
like they have fought a little bit it's
hard for both of them because of course
both of them can heal and Wolverine
seems to be kind of over it he kind of
throws over Deadpool on the ground there
turns around talks to him a little bit
and then starts to walk away but we can
then see Deadpool say something to him
we see him point at him we see Wolverine
stop turn around and walk back so we
know Deadpool said some type of smart
alec comment to him that probably pissed
him off because Wolverine turns around
goes and stabs him literally in the back
with both of his claws now real quick
when the music cut out and Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman were talking in the
announcement video we can see that Ryan
Reynolds says and I'm chasing him around
so we can assume here that Deadpool is
trying to get the help of Wolverine and
Wolverine keeps saying no but of course
dead pool is pretty tenacious we know he
doesn't quit and we know that when he
tries to be he can be extremely annoying
so no doubt that is what's happening
right here Deadpool is trying to get
Wolverine to help him but he's not
helping so Deadpool is resorting to
fighting and trying to piss him off in
order to get him to help and the pissing
him off part seems to be working now
they cut that scene there but eventually
they go on in this video to show us them
filming the next part of the scene
Wolverine walks up to Deadpool from
behind stabs him in the back and lifts
him up over his head and from there it
seems like Deadpool does a backflip to
sort of try to get out of this get out
of Wolverine's claws that are stuck in
his back so the fight scenes in this
film are going to be in true Deadpool
fashion and what I mean by that is that
they're gonna be bloody this is a fight
that we've been waiting for to see on
screen for a very long time Deadpool vs
Wolverine they're gonna do it right
they're gonna have all of the blood and
the guts in it we have swords going
through people claws going through
people and if we look at the next scene
we're going to have some explosions we
see a scene where Wolverine throws some
sort of a gas canister at Deadpool it
seemingly explodes and knocks him
through the wall but here is where it
actually gets quite interesting if you
notice the background there's a huge
20th Century Fox sign broken and
crumbled in the background now this is
some serious fourth wall breaking
because not only is Deadpool in the fox
universe but they have fully addressed
that they are in the fox universe and
they are kind of outside the fox
universe as well in the real world where
a real 20th Century Fox sign could be
unless they somehow put this in the
actual fox X-Men Universe maybe it's a
opening credit of some sort so it ends
up in the actual Universe however it
would not surprise me in the slightest
if they actually do end up in the real
world so to speak and what seems to be
happening here is Deadpool is killing
literally the fox Universe now we've
talked about this before in the channel
in the past that Deadpool might set up a
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe but
simply with the old Fox universe and if
you haven't read that story you really
should and if you want to get into the
comics be sure to check out my buddies
over at comicbookdirect.com they have
created a website and company that makes
comic book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so like I mentioned this is
setting up Deadpool to pretty much kill
the entire Fox Universe in fact it looks
like pretty much most of it is already
destroyed we see the 20th Century Fox
sign in Ruins we also see a white item
that is stuck in the ground on the right
side this could be some type of a rocket
or a missile or some type of a craft
whatever it is it is broken and it is
stuck in the ground seemingly fallen
from somewhere again basically showing
us that the whole world they're in is in
Ruins and chaos and this is where it
gets really interesting because based
off of some rumors that we've heard
about the plot of Deadpool 3 the TVA is
going to get Deadpool to essentially
help them prune a universe that they
haven't been able to prune because it is
controlled by the X-Men and Magneto is
the leader that could be the universe
that they're in right now or perhaps a
universe that was destroyed by the
actions of this other Universe perhaps
it was a incursion maybe this
Wolverine's World got destroyed maybe
even Deadpool is the reason that it got
destroyed and that's is why Wolverine
doesn't want anything to do with him
because remember Deadpool took Cable's
time travel device and went about a lot
of different points in time and Deadpool
actually went back in the past and saw
Wolverine when he killed his old will
put in quotes here Deadpool self because
we don't really count that Deadpool as
the real Deadpool and that's exactly
what Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool is going
to be doing in this film killing
characters like that killing the fox
universe and if Deadpool really is going
to take on an entire universe that is
ruled by the X-Men a universe where it's
said that the X-Men actually defeated
the Avengers Avengers such as Iron Man
Captain America and Thor and apparently
Magneto was going to have Thor's hammer
if Deadpool is going to take on a
universe like that he is 100 going to
need the help of Wolverine but based off
of what we're seeing here Wolverine
wants nothing to do with Deadpool at
first he wants nothing to do with
helping him or even seeing him and it
looks like it's going to be a pretty
epic fight that's waiting for us in
Deadpool 3. one of them at least we know
there's going going to be many fights
especially if he does take on the old
X-Men and I'm really curious to see how
this leads to Deadpool actually being in
the Marvel Cinematic universe's main
timeline he's obviously screwing up a
lot of different universes but perhaps
the tva's connection to Loki is how he
ends up in the main timeline and
hopefully if we're lucky he brings along
Wolverine with him as well but let us
know your thoughts about this awesome
Wolverine vs Deadpool scene in the
comments down below also let us know
what you think about Deadpool killing
the fox Universe do you like this do you
not like it what do you think of the new
Wolverine yellow suit let us know all of
your thoughts also don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway for a chance to win
an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
be sure to check us out on patreon check
out our website as well and we have a
Discord server if you'd like to join and
of course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf